[Music]  Kylie Jenner is bouncing back and fast  the 20 year old celebrated her daughter  stormy Webster's one-month birthday with  these sweet Mommy and Me pics on  Instagram and took to snapchat on  Thursday to show off her post-baby body  sharing this video rockin nothing but a  black crop top and matching underwear as  she posed it up in the mirror the sexy  snap comes just a week after Kylie  dissed the social media platform  tweeting quote so does anyone else not  open snapchat anymore or is it just me  ah this is so sad following the reality  stars tweet snap Inc stock plummeted the  company's market value dropped by 1.3  billion dollars according to Bloomberg  but later that day  Kylie back trashed tweeting still love  you though snap my first love  you